peut dire que oui ça fait vraiment du
bien ça fait d'arrêter de faire vous
savez le tour du pâté de maison un petit
kilomètre par si oui non c'est bien
c'est bien bon exercice et c'est bon
pour la tête et pour le moral
ah bah oui forcément ça fait un mois
qu'on attend ça forcément lent des frais
bride là il faut qu'on joue les golfeurs
ont pu retrouver leur golf 18 trous
après une privation liés au confinement
des retrouvailles apprécié par les
pratiquants comme par le gérant nous
lançons notre personnel retrouve une
bouffée d'oxygène et notre métier c'est
le sport c'est les liens sociaux c'est
la convivialité
donc les gens se retrouvent retrouvent
leurs copains retrouvent leur partie de
plaisir leur jeu on joue toujours aussi
mal qu'il ya un mois mais finalement la
philosophie c'est que voilà on prend du
plaisir et
et sur sur un sport extérieur donc pas
trop d'appréhension à l'évidence sur le
parcours c'est un véritable soulagement
de renouer enfin avec une activité de
plein air on a envie de retrouver le le
jeu tout simplement quoi ça fait plaisir
quoi ou d'un mois et la pratique c'est
ça fait du bien
on était un peu peiné pas pouvoir jouer
pendant pendant un certain temps surtout
que bon ben on est en plein air et on
reste à distance les uns des autres
donc voilà puis s'est fait plaisir
aujourd'hui on espère que cela continue
pour nous c'était une petite délivrance
une respiration temps de respiration
dans ce moment difficile
juste avant les fêtes avec 600 abonnés
deux millions de chiffre d'affaires
annuel et 25 emplois le golf de limère
c'est aussi une économie avec 40% de
ressources liées à son restaurant
toujours fermé l'établissement reste
fragilisée malgré ces retrouvailles